okay George is all yours through for the
day homie I'm through for the weekend and
you could sweep out all that rice you
realize that in the last 24 hours I've
flown four couples up the Las Vegas to
get married now what are you thinking
about you make nothing but though yeah
I guess you're right mmm-hmm you know
sometimes I think money isn't everything
that reminds me I've got the call Myrtle
see you later okay mr. Canton you are Hobie
Carrington aren't you yeah can't we go somewhere
where we could talk I'm listening go right ahead I
want to charter your plane oh I'm sorry I'm taking
the weekend off I just told my mechanic - I know
what you told your mechanic but you see this is
very important to me I have to get to Death Valley
getting married a hon of course not why should you
ask because all I've been doing is flying the milk
run for Cupid now I want to relax small restaurant
corner table soft light soft music soft shoulders
why not have to know with me it's the best offer
I've had today what are we going I had a table
reserved in the Italian death valley oh just
make out like I didn't say anything come on I'll
be you will I'll give you five hundred dollars
on the card on account o happy you so long you
see I might want you to stay there a few days
about that dinner you know I'm just
beginning to develop an appetite
by the way what's your name Oh catch
me get me fires go any right away all
right miss Forrest I'll meet you
at the plane as soon as I wash up
hi homie well Bob Donovan I always had a
hunch is one that was a washroom attendant
the time I suppose is pretty tough for a tired
old lights major to find a job these days what
happened couldn't you a hawk those golden
oak leaves used to sport around the China
Burma theater hey Marlo be keeping your eyes
and your ears toes and your mouth open you
haven't changed a bit that's right the same
all over the news to risk his neck for you
remember the tiny dropped me off in a Japanese
jungle left me even after three weeks to decode
messages for him sure are you are the best counter
espionage agent we had I could use your right now
sorry we're not going together don't you remember
I'm a civilian now we should see me out sometime I
knew Vince try beautiful what do you got I've
just changed uniforms not jobs right now I'm
looking for a man in here remember you to help
me find it not a chance I'm flying charted Oh
taking a certain young lady up to Death Valley
I'll be too busy to look for maps go ahead we'll
see about what you know I'll be able to find
you here in your office I presume you're all
set George just about say Hobie there's a storm
coming in you may have to fly over it I'll put
the oxygen in okay almost forest yes what is it I
miss fark you're miss Forrest I thought oh hello
mr. Canton you seem a little confused this is Miss
Catherine Forrest I used our name because mine is
too hard for people to remember and the countess
marrieds edifice go anywhere this is quite alright
with you isn't it to you I of course and who are
these other people's chaperones oh please out
your other passengers mr. van Busche mr. Forrest
and mr. Porter this is our pilot mr. Carrington
how do you do sir oh I'm afraid we may have to
fly over some weather just what does that mean
might have to use oxygen maybe we better not go
then Cathy what's the difference let's get going
never use extra night that's all right you'll be
sitting in front with me I'll take care of you it
sounds rather frightening what sitting with me or
using oxygen well maybe I try them both and find
no bystanders there are bad I use the dog who sees
as a matter of fact it's quite exhilarating really
it's not like the idea of all the company
but we having dinner together mother any
special seating arrangements pilot
miss Forrest I mean the countess
is sitting up front with me ourselves
comfortable anyplace you like thanks
there's a weather report Hobie oh
here's something else has just came
happy landing
they bought it I thought you were going to
watch the scenery oh yes indeed
I wouldn't miss it for the world
how did you happen to pick me for this trip are
you where the only charter pilot available what
do you mean the only one available well oh
they are the one way I booked up study for
the weekend must be quite a treat to be able
to handle me plane like you do being flying
on few years you weary fly are doing the
wall huh why didn't you tell me you were
bringing a whole party of people oh well it
was sort of a dream up and the last moment
I have trouble getting accommodations at the hotel
easily booked that in advance I'm
sure we be able to find something
I don't know it out and died
you feel well no I think I better
go back and sit in the cabin
Kenny will you change places with me
sure I doubt you Oh Cathy let me see that
I'll be glad is in a few Cathy I don't mind at all
look mister you can't stand up front
Chad why don't you go back and keep
mr. Porter company but he doesn't
need any company's prices leave
I've spent for a little dad left me about the
money you made during the war japanese prison
you've been telling that story so often floor
thank you beginning to believe it yourself
tonight when we get to Death Valley
what altitude of applying it about 14,000
better put on your oxygen mask you go
back to seat fasten your safety belt
arrests for people to put an oxygen mask
did you tell me panda gosh
try to keep your hands up you can't talk
to me that way that's up anywhere like I'm
flying this plane as sure as possible
to what happens to your passengers
wasn't even connected wanna be sued for negligence
you travel they kicked it loose way up here before
maybe less kicked it loose anyway this is not
the time to talk about we're coming into Death
Valley mr. Callaghan is right this is no place
to start an argument was it down van Busche
how do you feel miss for us holy woozi
but I'll be alright I'll take care of
her turn are you sure that oxygen hose
was connected before we took her of
course everything was inspected
what are you expecting to sale is
look mister you're asking for action
this won't do anybody any good we're safely
here I don't think Kathy will suffer any ill
effects well it isn't his fault if she isn't all
right yes it seems to me we are all being rather
childish come on Maggie let's go to that whale
what about our luggage it's potable bring it
can I give you answer yeah thanks
I still say there's a pilots fault
oh forget it Jan I think he's worth
a nice and so does Getti don't you
do you really I didn't notice him
too much what do you see about the
reservations please card sure thing
you have a reservations for the forest the
commerce defrost coal will eat Sir John Porter
and Jan van Busche I'm sure we have I'm sorry this
is mr. Porter how do you do mr. Walker I hope they
do mr. bolo I should thank you to my engineers
would know each other where have you operated
mostly mr. Walker you were to tell the truth I
have not already much since the wall excuse me
yes mr. van Busche mr. Walker probably though and
this is all tied up mr. Carrington I'm glad to
know you will you excuse me I have a long-distance
call what is our luggage I was going to bring it
up but I didn't have my union card so I like the
bellboys do it well we've been trying to get your
room mr. Carrington look they're putting full
you see we had our reservations here for some
time well that's all right just put me up in
the servants quarters who's married to get my
check engine room here's your key sir Thanks
well what about that dinner would plan with
a soft lights and the music is that out well we
have been invited to be mr. Walker's guests but
why don't you come to my room for a cocktail
after I freshen up alright see you later then
hello give it a manner to Grayson this is mr.
van Busche speaking I have a complaint to me
somebody's been going through my luggage yes
investigation no Superman I'm not surprised he
didn't think he got away from me that easy did you
I intended to be down here when he arrived my tend
to stay here anywhere romance no neighbors let's
stop this captain rather shall we too late now why
do you think that you are the only charter plane
available that's why I got a room in a crowded
hotel that's right tell me the anything important
happen on the way down I'll say it did somebody
kick the oxygen - who'll send my plane Catherine
force was almost killed I have been grounded for
life only this trip you're on is far from a
pleasure job it's a dangerous mission any time
that you get international rocket is exploding
atomic energy anything can happen why'd you have
to pick me for this job I did a nothing a dirty
work overseas because you're the only one I can
trust that's very flattering but I don't like
being drafted this way tell me what's all this
talk about been poisoned somebody went through his
luggage did you find anything suspicious yeah he
wears silk underwear khaki yeah will you do me
a favor how much is it this time I need $2,000
$2,000 well do I have to explain every time
I need a little money but this can't go on
I've been giving you so much money these last few
weeks okay put me through the usual third degree
but you can't have join me nope this
is business you cabled me from Honolulu
that you had some information on fraud
FLORIST that's why I sent for you would
you be interested in selling that
information why Tom what a question
how much I think you'll find me
generous enough you know I have
it right here but tell me why do you
want it that shouldn't concern you
let's just say I don't want to
see it get into the wrong hands
this must be the last alright but I don't
know why you have to be so stingy after
all it's just as much my money as it
is yours even though dad did leave it
to you I'm not stingy Claud it's just
that Oh I can't afford to spend it's
like get it come on let's go downstairs
they're most likely waiting dinner for us
I gotta get a proper perspective when
international cartels talk to work very
important you think a panda forest looks like the
type of would be mixed up with an international
cartel I didn't say that but I did check on the
forest they gave a house party in Honolulu and
one of the guests was a Korean who's to deliver a
certain map of the South Pacific island to one of
our agents well he never got there he was killed
and the map was never found I was there tired
with the rest of the party because they're Greek
passes on your plane was a member of that house
party when you suspect it's anybody's guess Mundi
uses but what about the countess well I'll be able
to tell you more about the countess in a couple of
minutes but it might not be what you want to know
I still think you should tell me why you
want this information on Claude no please
it's none of your business you're not giving
it to me I'm buying it I'm willing to pay a
good price do you have the money with you
I'll get it after dinner that reminds me I
better beginning downstairs yes and I should get
ready too we'll get together later this evening
hello countess I'm glad you're home good evening
mr. Carrington do see Dan thank you are all
you foreign women two-fisted drinkers no no the
second one is for you thanks martini and warm too
now that we are alone I want to tell you something
I'm very frightened of me no of course not about
what happened in the plane this afternoon you mean
the business about the oxygen yes that was meant
for me remember I was sitting up front with you
that's right why should anyone want to kill you
oh it's it's rather involved you see I was born on
the continent but I went to an English finishing
school and and then I married the count and when
he died he left me some rather valuable properties
and there are certain people's who are trying to
get those properties and I'm very frightened don't
be frightened but who are these people it could be
anybody on the plane today really will you help me
I always said there's nothing like
those English finishing school
you will help me want you sure who's going
to help me Wow shall we go downstairs go
ahead I join you later I hope you're
not too disappointed about not having
the dinner we plan no it's a funny thing I
just lost my appetite but I'll see you later
mr. Kent I don't know I was out at
the time you're sure you haven't
been drinking martini I love to prove it
okay can I help you I'll see you later
all right Endon will it be a double martini a
double yeah one martini game in this headache
maybe to make it go away yes for you Carrington
get lost lost the idea of going through my luggage
go away and start over again I'm serious had
a matter of explanation why don't you start
explaining how you happen to kick the oxygen holes
loose in my plane look you tried to cover up your
own negligence but blaming me for that accident
you're talking to the wrong guy it so happens I
intend to marry miss Forrest oh I'll send her my
condolences in the morning right now I don't feel
so well don't try to change the subject why'd you
go through my luggage oh I've taken all I'm going
to from you you open your Yap once more and I'll
close it for you oh yeah I'd like to see you try
don't get up boys is this one for me or do I have
to buy myself one as I'm getting come down yet
don't see that well please be a good boy and
go and caller will tell are we waiting for
I called your room that there was no answer so
I was downstairs to see if I could find you but
could we go outside and talk I've been outside the
desert air seemed to knock me right off my feet
I mean you were attacked how we can't Tokyo I'm
afraid we'd be overheard now maybe you understand
why I'm so frightened first it was catty now
it's you you haven't anything to worry about
as long as they don't run out of customers oh I
thought you meant what you said that you help me
what did you find in Jan's luggage why would
I want to go through a Jan's luggage oh I
thought maybe Claude or caddie put you up to
it you see yeah I'm suspicious of everybody
ooh
lovely we've been looking all over for you really
I just and Jen to call your room let's all have
a drink shall we your heads feeling better
mr. Carrington oh sure oh well I seem to get
the best when I gotta guess to her eyes oh I
guess the others will be along presently it's
been that way all along I'm always the one
on time to eat the rest of them never seem
to get hungry first I took time out for a
quick swim and I wished I've had time for
a horseback ride over the desert greatest
exercise in the world oh you sound like you
spend most your time outdoors I have oh my
I've engineered in practically every country
I understood capital so you were in the mining
business well geological engineering that's the
same thing I find the valuable mineral cement
together fella make the money why rain well
this is the most pleasant surprise I've had in
weeks oh really no this is the comedy fresco
murder how do you do it he was Forrest Thank
You mr. van Busche how are you and this fourth
brother mr. Ford honeydew miss Allison an old
friend of mine yes indeed as a matter of fact
we were more than just friends I used to be
mrs. Carrington then I'm sure you two must
have a great deal to talk over you excuse me
yes come Kathy would you excuse us miss Ellison
what's the matter why are you staring at me like
there's a lot of funny things that happen to me
today I've been holding this isn't funny this
is one you like to go for a walk in the garden
why didn't you let me know you were back we
mean let you know I didn't know where to find
you besides I didn't think you're interested in
hearing for me the last letter I got from you
I read in a bomb shelter it's funny how clear it
seems please sign in close papers I wanted a boy
I spent the whole night with
a chaplain talking about it
I regret it all my life you got married right away
didn't you oh you mean graduate but how do you